bonjour bienvenue à tous bienvenue dans
point de vue les fondamentaux vous les
connaissez 50 minutes de débat nos
quatre invités bien sûr vos questions
vos commentaires on les attend ce sont
le carburant de cette émission alors
tout de suite on va parler on a
chamboulé un peu notre sommaire pour
parler de zidane et de son annonce
inattendue il quitte le real madrid
un séisme dans la planète foot autre
thème celui du financement de l'islam de
france
avec cette question l'état doit-il s'en
mêler peut-il mettre de l'ordre dans un
océan d'opacité nous débattrons aussi du
cas de marion maréchal il faut
s'habituer à ne plus dire le pen la
jeune femme participe ce soir à un débat
après avoir lancé son université à lyon
tout récemment beaucoup lui prêtent
l'intention de revenir rapidement
politique elle répond que rien ne presse
nous verrons tout cela
enfin nous parlerons du patrimoine vous
le savez un loto est lancé pour sauver
des monuments en péril et bien à quel
est le monument en péril que vous
aimeriez sauver nous poserons la
question à nos invités et à vous chers
internautes
bonjour dur jésus guzman beach à beauvau
vous travaillez auprès de jean-luc
mélenchon et de la france insoumise
comme porte parole mme sur les questions
tellement de défense et de questions
internationales peuple merci d'être avec
nous bonjour olivier duhamel président
de la fondation nationale des sciences
politiques juristes politologues et
présentateur de médias polis sur europe
1 c'est le samedi matin à ne pas manquer
à 10h ou un podcast et vous est aussi
l'auteur des mots de macron petit
recueil paru tout récemment chez dalloz
bonjour m merci d'être avec nous alors
c'est vous qui avez piloté l'enquète qui
fait la couverture du magazine cette
semaine une enquête fouillée documenté
qui donc s'intitule l'argent caché de
l'islam et bonjour vincent trémolet de
villers directeurs-adjoints la rédaction
auteur de conversation française c'est
paru auxerre en 2016 alors tout de suite
je vous propose de nous deux nous
échauffer avec la nouvelle du jour les
nouvelles des sources et du foot c'est
le départ de zidane du real madrid un
coup de tonnerre que cette annonce
inattendue faite à la mi journée par le
sélectionneur
on va d'abord l'écouter puis on en parle
mais la décision dénoncée guidel
proximania
le cadre d'un trader derrière marie à
blé conel voilà voilà explique alain
poco loco locass à elio croquer seul
momento parlato soit dans le privé le
para me prépare à la plante y apparaît
le clou ce que ce moment de bordeaux le
yoyo croquer ce moment est importante et
est à ce moment tôt avis à casser des
sceaux par la para todos le bon moment
insiste c'est votre avis oui c'est bon
je viens parce que j'imagine des
imitateurs dont certains du matin qui va
maintenant illimité zidane parlant
espagnol
ça risque d'être quelque chose oui c'est
un basset un coup de théâtre encore très
réussie en face est une espèce de sortie
je suis pas comment la qualifier
je passais les majestueuses passé lego
en tout cas elle est allée parfaitement
faite puisqu'il a eu trois titres à la
suite qui pourra pas avoir mieux qu'il
ne peut plus rêver que d'une chose mon
avis c'est une sélection nationale
l'équipe de france pour être un joueur
qui gagnerait la coupe du monde comme
joueur et comme entraîneur
derrière ça apparemment il ya aussi le
fait que l'équipe qu'il a pour avoir un
grand entraîneur fois un grand club un
grand une grande équipe et apparemment
cristiano ronaldo le soir de la finale a
laissé entendre qu'il allait partir il y
aura peut-être d'autres départs et donc
il ne voulait peut-être pas aussi
continuer avec une équipe un tout petit
peu moins forte que celle qu'il a mené
jusqu'à la victoire de la championne ce
league donc il est parti avec beaucoup
d'alluré en tout cas beaucoup d'alluré
notre avis tranchés au jeu plutôt
d'accord c'est un grand succès et
maintenant peut-être que ce qui serait
bien c'est d'avoir six dames comme
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france ait
remporté une coupe du monde tout de
suite tout de suite mais bon ça permet
de faire un clin d'oeil aux amis
lensois puisque raphaël varane a été
sorti d'une formation du rc lens cci
dame qui l'a repéré qu'il a permis
d'avoir cette carrière magistral au real
madrid
donc voilà il touche quand ils touchent
quelque chose ça devient de l'or donc
voilà impériale dont il n'est dit mchugh
ah oui oui c'est l'empereur zidane
meilleur joueur du monde son époque
meilleur entraîneur de la meilleure
équipe d'europe mais en réalité on peut
presque dire en tout cas une des
meilleures équipes du monde
après doit y avoir des raisons à ça
parce que j'entends à ses explications
c'est le moment c'est pour l'équipe
on sait effectivement que il avait fait
deux saisons et demie absolument
remarquable on sait aussi qu'il n'avait
pas fait de recrutement cette année on
sait qu'un certain nombre de joueurs
parce que ronaldo qui se dit qu'il s'en
va qui reste mais c'est plus tout à fait
le ronald o dia
il ya trois ou quatre ans non plus donc
il était avec une équipe-type et après
qu'est ce qu'ils visent aujourd'hui moi
c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est ce qui
vise effectivement une équipe nationale
l'équipe de france ou alors j'en sais
rien je vous le dis c'est pure
supputation
ou alors peut-être d'intégrer
et bien la fédération qui dirige le
football en europe
il y à des élections très importante au
sein de la fifa en juin prochain en juin
2019 plus exactement en juin 2019
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui vit zidane
est ce que finalement il doit pas
devenir aussi un des dirigeants du
football en europe ou dans le monde
voilà j'en sais rien mais ça doit
signifier quand même quelque chose ce
départ si vous avez regardé la
conférence de presse il a dit aussi bon
qu'il avait été touché par les critiques
qui suit pas spécial et je me disais
mais un homme pareil qui avoue que les
critiques ont alors c'est peut-être de
la communication mais ça fait partie
aussi du personnage cette humilité quand
même dire quand j'ai reçu un sms
m'annonçant que vous chambouler un sujet
et que vous mettiez visible je me suis
dit d'abord je n'avais pas l'information
donc j'étais là regardez je suis dit
qu'est ce que tu peux dire après qu'il
peut dire que tu vas dire que il part au
sommet de sa gloire
c'est toujours le mieux de partir au
sommet de sa gloire et puis j'ai été
regardé ce que disait des experts et
tout et tout sépare ou sur votre savoir
ses menottes repartir au sommet de sa
gloire
puis je me suis dit qu'est ce qui peut
vouloir faire moi qui ne suis pas
spécialiste
peut-être un jour la succession des
champs et puis j'ai vu que les
expertises et pas ceux qui vivent
peut-être c'est la succession des champs
et puis j'ai rencontré un fan de zidane
ou j'ai posé les mêmes questions et il
m'a répondu exactement la même chose
des experts du foot sans le savoir parce
qu'on dit la même chose que les experts
et que les femmes
alors après ce qu'il en adviendra c'est
une autre histoire
juste un mot sur parce que la qualité
foot elle a été aussi fière celle de des
droits télé de la ligue 1 et cette
surprise aussi que finalement par le
biais d'un opérateur espagnol ces défis
noir à hauteur de ses plus plus la
majorité 53% je crois ça vous inspire
quel commentaire
c'est très curieux parce que le
le football prend des proportions
peut-être délirant 3 je pense délirante
notamment sur le plan financier il est
de moins en moins simple d'accès dans sa
fréquentation moi j'étais un passionné
de football qui joue beaucoup je
regardais beaucoup la ya trop d'argent
c'est ça de lui a trop de compétition on
en voit trop même à la télévision faut
se souvenir que quand on était jeune
quand il y avait un match on avait la
pression qui monte est deux jours avant
et puis on allume et tf1 il y avait le
match de football de la semaine et
c'était un peu le rayon de soleil de la
semaine quand on est un jeune passionné
là c'est devenu une industrie dont on
dit que c'est une bulle spéculative qui
pourrait exploser mais ce qu'on vérifie
quand même c'est que les gens continuent
à ses intérêts c'est la meilleure preuve
c'est que on commence cette émission
parle annonce d'un entraîneur qui quitte
son club
bon il c'est un champion du monde
français mais en espagne c'est quand
même pas un club un club français donc
donc voilà il ya ces proportions qui moi
je trouve son sont délirantes et rendent
ce sport éloigne en fait ce sport des
plus simples et des plus humbles il me
semble mais qui reste quand même des
restes de sept devant cette attraction
fatale en jetant un oeil ça se passera
comme ça pour la coupe du monde je pense
qu'on va dire avant le foot c'était
mieux avant maintenant c'est pourri ya
trop de fric c'est des athlètes qui sont
beaucoup plus gros et puis tout le monde
regardera et puis si la france est en
quarts de finale on en aura plus de
suggérer à s'arrêter que celui ci est
dépeint dans cette affaire quand même il
ya au moins une catégorie de gagnants
mais deux catégories beaucoup plus
importante de perdants et gagnants sur
les clubs qui vont recevoir plus
d'argent et un perdant ça va être
d'abord les amateurs de foot parce qu'on
va beaucoup beaucoup moins pressé avec
des horaires adaptés aux chinoises ont
rien appris voire de match et surtout
aussi les amateurs de cinéma parce que
oui parce que l'argent canal avait pour
le foot va bien le foot on ne sait
jamais vu le canal est quand même le
grand financeur du cinéma en france déjà
avec la baisse de canal depuis que
bolloré a pris les choses en main la
contribution au cinéma abc si canal+
comme on laisse entendre que perdre un
voire deux millions d'abonnés et ben ça
se répercutera inévitablement sur le
financement du cinéma français c'est
donc une très mauvaise nouvelle
commentaires sur l'argent du foot skis
ce qui se passe au niveau il ya trop
d'argent trop d'argent dans le foot et
pas assez d'impôts il ya énormément de
problèmes d'impôts dans les clubs
espagnols qui ne payent pas laisser sa
peau qui devrait à l'état il ya une
libéralisation qui est catastrophique ça
a été dit par les autres intervenants
mois d'accès pour les pour les simples
citoyens est beaucoup plus d'argent pour
les actionnaires dans ce domaine comme
dans d'autres
voilà il serait bon réguler un peu et
d'avoir moins de que l'argent soit moi
mettre des choses que je n'ai pas très
bien compris c'est que ça devient très
compliqué de regarder le foot parce que
si effectivement les matchs sont
répartis dans des bouquets j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il y avait huit ou neuf
bouquet jeunesse est pas l'expression
des huit ou neuf bouquet et si chaque
chaîne a123 bouquet ça veut dire que
pour garder foot il faut être abonné
combien de chaînes
vous êtes abonné à combien de bouquets
donc ça veut dire que ça coûte très cher
mais tu as l'arrivée la personne qui
aime le foot elle va aussi devoir payer
an d'abonnement très cher pour pouvoir
regarder le foot donc effectivement
c'est un peu un peu et de solutions pour
des malins qui pourrait faire un une
application partage foot celui qui a le
bon bout qu'est le bonjour le bon match
fait invité les voisins ils regardaient
ensemble mais plus qu'une solution du
couvercle du covoiturage chacun achète
tous les bouquets voilà alors à la
question que vous vous posez sur sur
twitter raison de quitter le real madrid
eh bien vous êtes 86% à nous répondre
que oui
de votre point de vue il a raison on va
forcément tout ça vous en quelques
commentaires marie-paule que va-t-il
faire maintenant
on a tenté d'y répondre mais on n'a pas
vraiment de certitudes sur ce plan john
peter le blanc c'est une bonne décision
du yuan balducci peut-être va-t-il
partir à paris on l'a évoqué aussi
acquis marbella dommage mais il part en
vainqueur à morteau de ces stratégies
qu'il est au début de sa carrière
d'entraîneur et quels débuts et bien et
encore yohan balducci ça vous inspire
tous il n'avait pas réussi son départ en
tant que footballeur là c'est un départ
au sommet de sa gloire et herby
larosilière il a fait un choix
intelligent donc une quasi unanimité
pour dire que c'était le bon moment
comme il l'a dit lui même
nous allons changer complètement de
sujets nous allons parler de l'argent de
l'islam en france et notamment à partir
donc de cette enquête très fouillée que
à laquelle vous avez participé matthieu
aron ce qui ressort c'est que beaucoup
d'argent circule celui versé par les
pays musulmans par les donateurs privés
par les dons des fidèles
mais alors où va-t-il ça c'est la grande
question qui contrôle les flux là c'est
le flou artistique
pour autant l'état doit-il s'en mêler
nous allons discuter tout cela dans un
instant mais d'abord je vous propose de
vous arrêter sur une photo c'est une
photo qui a été prise par une
journaliste de figaro live c'était la
sorbonne je voudrais juste une réaction
de votre part on voit donc la cour de la
prestigieuse université avec plusieurs
étudiantes voilées dévoile même y
compris
détenu s'apparente à la burqa je
rappelle quand même que le voile n'est
pas interdit à l'université mais juste à
une réaction à cette à cette photo
olivier duhamel
bon je pense qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de photos d'universités américaines
anglaises allemandes qui pourrait
ressembler à cette photo est donc ça me
bouleverse pas autant que peut-être vous
d'autres en tout cas non je voulais
juste avoir une réaction si vincent
c'est comme frappant moi j'étais
étudiant dans cette cour c'était pas la
même chose après il ya un phénomène que
judy kepel a décrit dans les universités
du développement d'un islam politique à
l'échelle des étudiants et même dit il
enfin les chaînes maintenant d'un
certain nombre d'enseignants donc vous
avez des maîtres de conférences qui
défendent une vision
politique de cette religion et donc
c'est un sujet d'inquiétude en tout cas
d'après quelques cas étudiés là dessus
bon après moi ces étudiantes on ne sait
pas si elles font partie de cet islam
politique mais ça révèle que ce sujet
est au coeur des inquiétudes françaises
et qu'on n'a pas fini d'en parler
puisque il est visible maintenant dans
toutes les situations de la vie
quotidienne sorbonne où la responsable
de l'unef marianne pougetoux qui est
elle-même vous allez ça a fait une
polémique ces derniers jours mathieu bon
effectivement la photo pourrait être
prêt dans une université étrangère à
l'oral frappe toujours puisqu'on est
donné dans ce lieu anciens etc à la
sorbonne
maintenant il est tout à fait possible
de porter le voile à l'université
voilà la loi n'est absolument pas mise
en cause par cette photo
après moi je suis un petit peu gêné
parce que je ne sais pas dans quelles
circonstances a été pris la photo sont
des étudiants qui sont voilà donc c'est
pour ça que je peux aller plus loin un
commentaire les étudiantes sont
peut-être se trouvent certains ne peut
être étranger on sais pas moi aussi j'ai
étudié ici des fois des étudiants
étrangers qui viennent avec un clair
coutume mais c'est vrai que le port du
voile se se répondent écouter certains
invoquent la laïcité mais justement
c'est ça c'est pas un bon argument
puisque la loi autorise le port de la
ligue
moi personnellement en tant que
représentant d'une organisation
féministe je trouve que c est tragique
parce que ça ça va à l'encontre des
droits de la femme et c'est utilisé par
un certain islam politique comme comme
vecteur de messages comme un message de
son idéologie s est jamais simple de
l'unef qui a fait parler d'elle
bon c'est déjà prononcés ce que c'est ce
que j'avais déjà dit je crois même sur
ce plateau et je répète je ne regrette
qu'une leader syndical qui est censé
défendre également la cause féministe
port quelque chose porte un voile qui
est qui la dessert regardons un instant
bien la photo et les baskets
qu'évidemment on dit tous voile en
vérité
trois quatre ou cinq corps d'un foulard
mais pas plus que ça mais déjà quand on
dit voile mais aussi d'aider des
tuniques longues
donc on appelle foulard voile après un
appel port du voile islamisme intégriste
son appel et clanisme intégré jihadiste
sur un appel déjà dix terroristes
il faut pas faire toutes ses passions
les unes après les autres parce que ça
n'a pas de sens mais ce qui m'intéresse
sur la photo c'est la jeune femme de dos
à gauche de la photo parce que c'est pas
seulement des baskets qu'elle a des
basques jean et elle a un foulard
islamique et donc ça prouve quand même
la complexité de la chose il n'est pas
dit que cette jeune femme
il est même presque 10 de ce que l'on
pourrait interpréter de la photo que
cette jeune femme n'est pas en doctrine
est soumise à un mari qui l'a contraint
de porter une tenue parce qu'il la
laisserait pas sortir comme ça en jiming
par maison donc on peut pas avoir une
interprétation univoque eux mais si on
est pour l'égalité si on est féministe
on peut pas accepter ça chez de la photo
ça montre aussi vous l'avait dit et
olivier mathieu en dix ans à eau pour
être dans une université anglo-saxonne
ça montre aussi la querelle qui se
déroule aujourd'hui en france
intellectuel entre ceux qui défendent un
modèle multiculturel à l'anglo saxonne
et ceux qui défendent un modèle
républicain universaliste et qui
considèrent que nous ne pouvons pas
appliquer ce qui se fait dans les
universités du canada d'angleterre ou
des etats unis c'est je peux être
républicain je peux être républicain ce
que je suis et trouvé que on peut à
l'université porter un foulard
cela me que si on est musulmane mais
qu'on a envie de porter l'accusation
l'autorisation ll aujourd'hui l'occident
elle compatible avec républicain jon
l'ambiguïté du terme multiculturelle
c'est que on en fait souvent synonyme de
communautarisme vous pouvez très bien
être d'un certain point de vue
multiculturelle est très opposée au
communautarisme c'est pas la même chose
c'est républicain et accepter que des
gens
une diversité religieuse affiché
maintenant du financement tout de suite
mais d'abord je vous propose d'écouter
hakim el karoui hakim el karoui c'est
cet ancien conseiller de jean pierre
raffarin qui maintenant à l'oreille des
manuels macron qui a beaucoup travaillé
et écrivent c'est lui qui est l'auteur
aussi du livre sur l'islam une religion
française il était l'invité de
marie-laetitia bonavita pour figaro live
c'était au début de cette année il ya
beaucoup d'argent on n'a pas besoin
d'argent public on n'a pas besoin de
changer la loi de 1905
on a besoin de collecter une petite
partie de cet argent pour le mettre au
service de l'intérêt général
aujourd'hui il est tenu par des mains
privées qu'ils utilisent soit pour
eux-mêmes soit pour leurs projets à eux
il ya de l'argent qui va dans les
associations ces associations sont pour
la très grande majorité d'entre elles
islamistes donc il faut arrêter avec ça
il faut il faut mettre de la
transparence du professionnalisme et
puis faut créer un guichet donc il faut
créer un système où cette organisation
soutenue extraire landaise parler car
l'association
voilà enfin disons une association parce
que là on va être vraiment et dans le
cultuel une association de 1905 aurait
la capacité à se mettre au milieu des
flux en travers des flux et à prendre
sont dit mme mathieu aron j'ai lu donc
l' enquête que vous avez réalisé pour
l'obs ce qui ressort on se dit mais
finalement l'état n'a jamais réussi à
contrôler pendant les décennies passées
large en islam en france pourquoi et
comment pourrait-il y arriver
aujourd'hui une bonne question
c'est une très bonne question encore que
la situation évolue d'année en année il
est évident que c'est une religion qui a
pris de l'importance et ses trente ou
quarante dernières années en france
incontestablement il ya beaucoup plus de
pratiquants qu'elle n'en avait donc les
questions et éventuellement les
problèmes et il y a des problèmes se
posent au fur et à mesure ce qui
explique des choses maintenant ce qui
moi m'a frappé dans cette enquête c'est
on vit toujours avec l'idée que l'islam
est une religion on encore l'idée dé
l'islam religion relève est un peu
excessif mais pauvre pauvre légion des
cadres les gens alors ça existe toujours
puisque incontestablement il manque de
lieux de culte ça c'est évident quarante
mise et demie l'église catholique 2500
lieux de culte musulmans et sur les 2500
200 véritable mosquée donc il là il ya
un problème mais et c'est ce qu'on a
montré dans l' enquête de l'ops il ya de
l'argent il y a de l'argent d'abord
parce que des fidèles et les pratiquants
qui sont au nombre à peu près deux
millions sont des gens qui pesait 130
heures de noyon friel a380 selon les
estimations des gi qui ont existé et
elle a donc et c'est à peu près ce que
donnent les catholiques il dira c'est
très intéressant autour de 100 euros et
les catholiques et des musulmans dans à
peu près nulle où les musulmans
pratiquants et les catholiques
pratiquants donne à peu près les mêmes
sommes au total on est vu le nombre de
pratiquants à 300 400 millions d'euros
qui existe là il y aussi ce qui pourrait
être interrogé comment les mosquées
récupère ou ne récupère pas et là on est
dans l'opacité absolue avec l'adaptation
avec une évaporation totale de tout
l'argent qui provient du marché du halal
et on ne sait pas aujourd'hui en france
comment les mosquées récupère ou ne
récupère pas de l'argent sur ce marché
là ce qui est quand même une véritable
question ensuite troisièmement et pour
aller vite il ya quelque chose assez
frappant c'est que les associations
qu'elles soient d'ailleurs loi de 1905
ou loi 1901 à l'obligation à partir du
moment où elle récolte plus de cent
cinquante trois mille euros de dons de
publier leurs comptes aux jo il se
trouve que cette on a mangé vérifier je
suis passé pas mal de temps
en consultant le dio les diocèses de
france tous les dossiers de
publiant le sujet au centime près après
exact ou pas ça c'est à vérifier mais
ils publient tous au centime près les
associations qui construisent des
mosquées associations qu'elle soit 19
cents à 1905 associations musulmanes
public très rarement leurs comptes moi
j'ai regardé j'ai je suis tombé sur
trois quatre associations qui
construisent des mosquées par exemple à
massy voilà du sein parce que de mémoire
ou aux ulis qui elles publient leurs
comptes
mais toutes les autres et elle soit
infiniment plus nombreuses y compris les
très grandes mosquées la mosquée de
paris mais il ne restait de paris ne
publie pas ses comptes mois à la mosquée
de paris j'ai été les voir ils m'ont
confié des comptes
je dois reconnaître que leur compte ce
que j'ai eu comme document est un
document que je vais qualifier d'un
complet dont il ya un souci d'opacité
quand même opacité déjà sur l'islam le
cliché de l'islam pauvres en france et
tout ça george's osmanovic vous avez
vous avez découvert aussi que c'était
peut-être un peu plus compliqué enfin
découvert ya longtemps il n'y a pas un
islam en france il ya des islams temps
en temps dans l'idéologie que dans les
moyens dont il dispose pour pour leur
culte et il y a des l'islam très riche
et un islam totalement incontrôlée donc
il ya déjà ce que vous avez dit qui est
un problème nous pensons qu'il faut plus
d'état
et même si l'état n'a pas se mêler des
affaires de culte l'état peut contrôler
et il a déjà fait longtemps avec la
l'église catholique la loi 1905 permet
beaucoup de choses allaient mal elle est
mal connu mais il y a il y à il y à un
islam extrêmement riche qui est celui
qui vient des financements du qatar ou
d'arabie saoudite et sur lesquels on est
d'autant plus qu'on serait d'autant
d'autant moins que beaucoup de nos
hommes politiques sont très liés pour
une manière différente avec ces deux
pays là et on laisse faire beaucoup de
choses alors que alors qu'on devrait
conte de réagir ils comptent a eu dans
m'étais senti côté liens politiques et
donc peut-être
oui bien sûr moriani ça je ne sais pas
mais je pense qu'il ya deux types de
problèmes il ya d'une part le problème
de financement étranger par des états
avec des velléités de puissance
c'est-à-dire que quand vous entendez le
président turc erdogan menacé
ouvertement la france quand elle fait
une déclaration qui ne lui plaît pas de
dire vous allez voir si si vous
continuez on va vous le faire payer etc
et le l'état turc finance largement de
ce que c'est vers ce beaucoup d'argent
en france aussi donc ça doit être
vérifiée et à quelles fins et puis en
dehors de l'argent de l'état étranger il
ya une autre difficulté qui est il faut
respecter la liberté de confiance il
faut respecter la liberté d'expression
il faut lutter contre une idéologie
totalitaire
si on emploie des vieux mot mais ça veut
rien dire là-dessus fascisante nord tout
cas destructrice des libertés
destructrice des êtres humains qui à
l'islamisme radical
bon et c'est facile à dire mais c'est
beaucoup plus difficile à faire pour
définir qu'est ce qui l'attend dans
cette lutte relève de la tâche de l'état
de la loi qu'est ce qui relève de la
bataille de la société si vous voulez
quand on a mené la bataille contre le
communisme par exemple que ceux qui
pensaient que à juste titre que le
communisme était où était devenu en tout
cas l idéologie d'état trail totalitaire
où l'on n'a pas interdire par une trêve
respect de notre histoire pour les
réseaux partie on n'a pas interdit parti
communiste on a mené une bataille
politique culturelle sociale contre le
communisme les uns d'emblée d'autres
comme le nouvel observateur un peu plus
tard chacun à son nom bon il ya quantité
de choses contre l'islamisme radical qui
relève de la bataille des idées et à
l'évidence quand il s'agit du terrorisme
ça va être en battue interdit
sanctionnés par la loi
mais juste avant et juste avant les gens
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ce qui me frappe
c'est que des gens disent mais de même
des gens intelligents des gens ouverts
des genres libéraux ou démocrates disent
par exemple il faut interdire le
salafisme mais c'est vrai on va dire que
ça aurait dire définir comment le
salafisme et interdire comment ça n'a
pas de sens en revanche c'est ce qu'il
faut pas contrôler l'argent et du coup
dans certains cas interdire quand il
s'agit de professer des tests totalement
discriminatoire et contraire aux valeurs
de la république probablement que oui
donc ce sont des questions compliquées
l'objectif c'est à dire si on veut
laisser pour effectivement d'abord il
faut aérer commencer par appliquer la
loi parce que c'est un certain nombre
d'associations certaines sont peut-être
des associations simplement
d'organisation du culte musulman et
d'autres souvent dissimule une vision
beaucoup plus politique de l'islam vous
parlez de la turquie mais en gros les
foyers de financement c'est la turquie
c'est l'arabie saoudite c'est l'iran et
ses frères musulmans c'est ça c'est eux
qui essayent décès mais un islam
politique avec une vision de la société
avec un imaginaire qui va de la
naissance jusqu'à la mort donc ça
s'appelle une idéologie et ces gens là
utilisent les possibilités que donne
notre société libérale que l'on doit pas
remettre en cause pour faire avancer
leur idéologie donc il faut appliquer la
loi mais la difficulté moi je pense
c'est que beaucoup beaucoup de gens
abordent cette question avec à l'esprit
la hiérarchie et l'organisation de
l'église catholique c'est à dire que
pour eux ils pensent l'islam comme si
c'était un autre catholicisme donc il
faut faire le 10 905 de l'islam le
concile vatican ii de l'islam mais pour
qui un concile vatican ii faut qu'il y
ait un vatican il n'y a pas de vatican
en islam il n'y a pas de structure vous
parliez des diocèses tout ailleurs
mathieu aron ya pas de découpage
territorial qui soit équivalent il n'y a
pas de cardinal de paris
donc on est devant un flou total une
espèce de ça pourrait ressembler à
certaines un certain protestantisme aux
états unis avec énormément d'entités et
il est beaucoup plus difficile de ce
fait de travailler avec ça alors il ya
le rêve qui a vu nicolas sarkozy et qui
apparemment traversé l'esprit emmanuel
macron d'organiser un peu la force du
poignet un islamo restructurer
hiérarchique mais ça va quand même
contre même le corpus doctrinal de cette
religion qui n'est pas organisé de la
même façon que la région connaît juste
pour alimenter le débat je donne la
parole dans un instant mathieu c'est
effectivement une interview de mohammed
moussaoui lequel tu as représentants de
l'islam plutôt de marocains on va dire
en france et qui est un ancien
responsable du cfcm qui disait dans le
figaro ce matin c'est son point de vue
il faudrait finalement mettre ça à
niveau du département vous parliez des
diocèses ment en disant c'est la bonne
échelle pour les relations entre les
institutions et les fidèles juste ça
peut être une idée qu'en parler de
l'organisation qui n'est pas qui
n'existe pas pour le moment oui mais ça
c'est le représentant des marocains et
puis le représentant de la turquie va
dire moi je ne suis pas d'accord et
celui que je pense que sans avoir lu
mais a priori en ayant travaillé pour
cette enquête dessus ce qui m'a été dit
si effectivement autant on avait des
réelles quand on sait tous ce problème
de représentativité au sein du cfcm
instance nationale autant les cfcm
départementaux régionaux pour un
fonctionnement qui de l'avis général
fonctionne mieux et plus ouvert et plus
efficaces donc ses préférences après moi
juste de remarque que sur le financement
étranger on a on a on n'a de souci on a
un financement par des états étrangers
mais celui là
compte tenu des relations qu'on a avec
ses états il est tracé et plasma natixis
ont les idées et les sommes qu'on a pu
réunir sont des sommes qui ne sont pas
des sommes colossales sont pas des
sommes considérables et qui n'ont
pratiquement et qui n'ont rien à voir
par exemple avec le financement de la
russie pour l'église orthodoxe
on est vraiment sur une tout autre
échelle et s'est pas véritablement là où
il ya un souci ya par contre une vraie
interrogation un point noir une zone
grise on appelle ça comme on veut
vis-à-vis du financement de riches
particuliers étrangers
moi j'ai recueilli des témoignages de
gens qui ont été et ont eu des
responsabilités importantes au sein des
frères musulmans qui en sont sortis
aujourd'hui mais qui ont étudié comment
ils allaient dans tel ou tel pays en
arabie saoudite en particulier et qu'il
ramenait les valises de billets etc
financement là on ne les traces pas
c'est peut-être pas passé peut-être
aussi parce qu'on se donne pas
totalement les moyens de le faire si
vous voulez donc je pense que si déjà
que ce soit au sein de la façon dont les
associations doivent respecter la loi
dans la manière dont on doit voir quel
argent rentre en france et dans la façon
ce dans une zone zone dans un autre
secteur dont on n'a pas parlé qui sont
l'organisation des pèlerinages et du
grand pèlerinage à la mecque où il ya un
nombre d'escroqueries absolument
considérable ce qu'on sait depuis des
années
si déjà on acceptait de regarder ce qui
se passe et tout simplement de respecter
la loi
simplement ça et de la faire appliquer
alors on aurait déjà fait je crois un
gros progrès je crois en
quelques remaniements appliquée
appliquer la loi précitée
enfin ça s'applique à des états normaux
mais encore une fois le qatar et
l'arabie saoudite sont des sondés
monarchie de droit divin et quant à
molenbeek lors de l' enquête
il avait essayé prouver que 9 millions
d'euros l'équivalent 9 millions d'euros
a été envoyé par un prince qatari l'état
a répondu pas froisser la duchesse de
berry qui l'envoyaient je suis roi et la
casse et royal est alors que eux-mêmes
reçoivent l'argent de cette cassette
royal pas c'est un peu se moquer se
moquer du monde et de faire c'est pas de
ma faute alors qu'en fait ils savent
très bien que qui fait quoi à ce niveau
là dans l'eure dans leur état et oui il
faut que l'état mettre le son nez là
dedans je répète en france quand cela
était nécessaire et la constitution
civile du clergé voilà faut que les gens
comprennent que c'est un état laïc c'est
une république et que en suivant les
règles qui s'appliquent à tous tout va
bien avant tout le monde
vous êtes une petite majorité à répondre
effectivement que l'état doit se mêler
du financement de l'islam en france 55 %
de oui à notre question sur twitter avec
pas mal de réactions aussi celle
d'ariane
il y à une recrudescence du port du
voile et des tenues entre guillemets
fait entre dans des villes comme roubaix
c'est assez inquiétant
philippe ménard heureusement que l'état
n'a pas le contrôle sur le financement
des religions sinon ce serait la mort de
la laïcité tant que la loi est respectée
altaï cas je pense que l'état n'a pas
empêché l'argent d'entrées en france
mais doit s'inquiéter des contreparties
à morteau dos le financement de l'islam
comme tout financement doit être
transparent et encore quelques je vous
en livre quelques unes elles sont
vraiment nombreuses je les découvre un
peu avec vous je suis d'accord pour que
l'état se mêle du financement pour mieux
cadrer les dérives amir 4 aucun état ne
doit financer les mosquées en france ce
sont les français et les françaises de
confession musulmane qui doivent assurer
le financement est macabre ronito que
j'ai perdus en route si on veut imposer
un islam de france il serait bien
d'imposer des mosquées françaises gérées
par des capitaux français et non pas par
un pays où des particuliers étrangers
s'étaient vidées de chevènement s'était
jamais sa structure
et bien pas son si vous voulez bien à
notre troisième thème on va parler de
marion maréchal qui a donc effacé le nom
de le pen
elle intervient ce soir dans une soirée
débat à propos de mai 68 organisé par le
magazine incorrect et la semaine
dernière elle avait présenté son
institut des sciences politiques qui
doit ouvrir à lyon à la rentrée
prochaine alors que signifient ces
activités des jalons pour un retour en
politique elle même ne l'exclût pas tout
en affirmant qu'elle se donne le temps
on va l'écouter c'était il ya une
semaine à la télé lyon métropole on
écoute moi je considère que les gens qui
estiment que d'ici 2-3 qui a dix ans ce
sera telle ou telle personne qui sera
légitime pour porter les idées de tel ou
tel camp cd raisonnement un peu
hasardeux enfin je veux dire quand on
voit que en quelques années à peine
l'ancien secrétaire général adjoint à
l'elysée devenu président de la
république voilà les choses vont très
vite donc je pense que ceux projetaient
excessivement sur telle ou telle
personne c'est un peu hasardeux vrac ou
moi je construis des choses une fois de
plus je suis incapable de rester
indifférente à l'état de mon pays mais
encore faut-il que pour moi le combat
m'apparaissent le plus adéquat et le
plus juste regard de ce que je peux
amener tout simplement juste pour
compléter son propos à la question du
jour posée par le figaro sur souhaitez
vous le retour en politique de marion
maréchal qu'on a posé aujourd'hui sur le
site
je crois que le résultat de mémoire 59 %
de oui donc là aussi c'est bon c'est une
majorité de huit rappaz massive une
réaction bas côté là on a ici le maître
de la média politique et l'histoire de
marion maréchal et quand même
comment dire un déroulé presque
chimiquement pur de ce que permet
aujourd'hui les médias pour la politique
parce qu'elle fait à peu près rien
après avoir lancé son école depuis six
mois et il suffit qu'elle bouge un doigt
qu'elle aille aux états unis qu'elle
fasse une déclaration pour que tout
s'arrête et que l'on second se fixe sur
elle en disant elle va être là en gros
on cherche quel est votre l'opposant où
l'opposante emmanuel macron ça va être l
donc objectivement elle exerce une
attraction médiatique très très
importante c'est une star c'est une
vedette puisqu'il est un c'est même un
record du monde je pense c'est à dire
que maintenant mais elle n'a parlé aux
etats-unis 9 minutes
si vous prenez 9 minutes et si vous
voyez la couverture médiatique qui a
suivi pendant deux mois dans un silence
total
jamais vous avez un rapport de durée
d'expression et de relais d'image de
couverture de muse et c'est de cette
ampleur c'est du jamais vu
c'est la meilleure des pointes
souvenez-vous le jour où elle était aux
etats-unis c'est le jour il ya une autre
vie pauvre laurent wauquiez était chez
ruth elkrief pour essayer de se défendre
et de reprendre la main sur ses
déclarations secrète n'était pas secret
et il a été absolument éblouissant
ébloui être anéantie par pape accepte
par cette déclaration de marion le pen
après derrière politiquement c'est quand
même beaucoup plus compliqué c'est à
dire que il faut un certain nombre de
circonstances pour qu'elle puisse
revenir et ça ressemble je pense que
elle doit avoir en tête ce qu'elle fait
emmanuel macron parce que tout le monde
a en tête c'est fait une manuelle macron
mais emmanuel macron a bénéficié d'un
certain nombre de choses de
l'empêchement de françois hollande
du fait que benoît hamon a fait 6 % donc
sans doute doit-elle rêver que laurent
wauquiez ce hameau knees et que marine
le pen soit empêché alors là peut-être
faire quelque chose mais on est con on
en est quand même loin
donc je pense qu'il ya quand même un
très fort contraste entre l'attraction
médiatique qu'elle exerce et la réalité
politique qu'elle pourrait incarner
aujourd'hui en tout cas je me tourne
vers
le maître en médias et politiques et l'
autre chose de formidable pour elle ce
qu'elle a une belle gueule mais regardez
les mouvements populistes qui marchent
ils ont substitué j'exagère à peine en
disant qu'ils ont substitué des leaders
à des leaders moche des leaders beau
gosse et vous c'est le cas assez
largement vos triche c'est le cas du
mouvement ou 5 étoiles regarder comparer
salvini
les griots la db griot c'est le cas dans
beaucoup d'autres pays t elle
franchement y'a un casting non mais un
casting qui aident mais considérablement
surtout à l'époque de la crétinisation
médias politiques si vous voulez parce
que le nous prend une place absolument
considérable qu'ils n'avaient pas avant
elle est beaucoup plus éligible elle est
beaucoup plus évident que
que marine le pen marine le pen quoi
qu'on en pense et où la crème dans son
visage encore quelque chose de dur de
deux d'extrême droite entre guillemets
dans l'expression physique que que de
regarder elle n'a pas du tout ça on vous
attendait sur des propos de fouet mais
j'ai malheureusement sans doute raison
du chantier crossman vie qui réagissait
à des propos justement salvini ça va les
gars manquaient pas non plus souvent
sexy justement choisi un kiala non c'est
pas juste à gauche du parti de me
mouvoir 5 étoiles et batista qu'il est
beau gosse qui qui entraîne des gens
dits maillot est là pour montrer qui
c'est un gendre comptable tout à fait
sympathique et le professeur on peut
voter mais il n'est pas charismatique et
puis je vous dirais que par macro ou si
il a un peu choisit de se laisser
populisme du centre est attisée en
politique si on n'a pas un nom il faut
vraiment physique
voilà pour revenir à un an marion marion
maréchal plus le pen elle est quand même
très le pen mais ça c'est quand même une
mafia parce qu'il faut rappeler que son
école elle est où est-ce qu'elle
enregistrait elle est enregistrée au
château de montretout donc j'ai pas pas
le pen
donc il ya une continuation du
fonctionnement familial qui joue qui
bascule d'un côté à l'autre
et justement comme des baux populiste
mais d'extrême droite manoeuvre la
population échanges change les idées
alors est là elle a dans son parti c'est
à dire le front national un boulevard à
l'avenir puisque le social a été dégagée
avec avec filippo actuelle représente ce
qu'était le front national avant
c'est-à-dire très à droite sur les
questions sociétales et un autre en même
temps extrêmement est ultra libérale et
je pense qu'elle a tout préparé parce
que là la parole est effectivement que 9
minutes mais neuf minutes ou à
washington devant le grand rassemblement
des ultraconservateurs qui en plus
financer son école avec bolton donc
c'est une dernière remarque c'est un
parti qui est assez extraordinaire quand
il va chercher qui soi-disant veut
défendre la france et les français mais
va chercher soi chez poutine soit 11,2
unis dans les deux cas je ne douterai
conservateur son argent pour continuer
ces petites activités politiques voilà
elle va elle va revenir à une belle
gueule ella ella les forces de droite se
vont s'allier au front national avec
wauquiez elle a de l'avenir
matthieu aron elle est la raison
d'organiser cette rareté
en tout cas elle se débrouille bien faut
le reconnaître tout ce que vous avez dit
est juste alors effectivement on peut
considérer qu'il ya une forme de
surexposition médiatique
peut-être toujours est-il qu'elle
incarne
et elle s'est incarné quelque chose de
très particulier qui est la passerelle
pour entre la droite et l'extrême droite
c'est ça marion maréchal qui n'est plus
le pen et qui n'est plus le pen
justement pour incarner cette passerelle
entre la droite et l'extrême droite et
le fait de développer un corpus ou
appeler ça comme ça une forme c'est à
travers son école de corpus idéologique
qui puisse correspondre à cela c'est
bien pour ça que l'on s'intéresse à elle
alors elle est très jeune elle a été la
plus jeune députée de dispense je crois
de la république est là certain brio
mais ce qu'elle veut incarner c'est ça
et alors elle sait qu'elle doit partir
effectivement vu son âge il faut
qu'elles se mettent en ordre de bataille
maintenant est-ce qu'elle y arrivera
j'en sais strictement rien mais si
effectivement quand on regarde mais
le sondage que vous avez donné des
lecteurs du figaro ils ont l'air plutôt
contents de la voir arriver ils ont là
plutôt contents de la voir arriver c'est
à dire qu'elle incarne quelque chose qui
est différent de ce qu incarne
effectivement sa tante
vous avez passé deux sont atteints ou la
télé lire on a ses traits au test parce
que c'est pas une déclaration de
candidature mais c'est quand même pas
très loin dire aujourd'hui c'est un
bazar de savoir qui se sera dans c'est
quand même alors imaginer que d'ici là
imaginer qu'elle crée la league des cinq
étoiles imaginez que voquer ses tricks
de plus en plus et et marie fort bien
imaginer qu'elle soit la force montante
comme vous comme ça a été dit je pense
qu'à ce moment-là ce tas soutenir ce
serait pas mal toujours juré pas
d'alliance avec le front national
message est juste promu en national et
tout est possible justement à ce propos
une info qui est tombé reste là et nous
perdons marine le pen propose une liste
commune a dit nicolas dupont-aignan dans
une lettre ouverte qu'elle publie
aujourd'hui parce que le lancer député
européen a quitté le front national pour
rejoindre nicolas dupont aignan là on
voit la bataille des européennes qui va
être le moment de la recomposition
politique réalisée donc chacun plus
d'intentions pote élections européennes
même si ça veut pas dire une chose à un
membre du scrutin mais qui mettait
dupont aignan la seo
c'est beaucoup beaucoup risqué comme je
pense à du joueur oullins et a pris pour
terminer sur marion maréchal je pense
qu'elle elle bénéficie de l'absence
d'opposition à maquereau c'est à dire
qu'il ya quand même une recherche
peut-être inconsciente presque
médiatique d'opposants il y en a pas
parce que pour le moment ils sont
inaudibles et donc il ya elle qui se
dégage est de votre côté dans votre camp
il me semble que françois ruffin
pourrait avoir un une trajectoire
équivalente parce qu'il l'a aussi pour
lui
l'attrait de la nouveauté des formes
politiques un peu insaisissable
une pratique de la modernité que jean
luc mélenchon
le pen c'est pas la nouveauté et son
père maréchal dans maréchal le pen
allait avec le pen pendant des années et
des années avec les nazis et plus givré
d'ukraine à lvov pour célébrer la
division ss galicie n'a elle représente
un vieux courant des schistes est elle
la khadra parfaitement c'est la droite
de la droite qui est prêt à aller se
soumettre à l'étranger et surtout
recevoir de l'argent à prendre le
pouvoir en france
vous pensez que france n'a aucun rapport
mais les français non je vais parler
simplement des possibilités politiques
est ce que il incarne pas à la gauche de
la gauche opposée une espèce de
nouvelles formes politiques très
attractive très méchant échappé que
françois le cherche un élément de la
france un solide et que ensemble créons
ce mouvement où justement l'idée n'est
pas de faire des petits bouts ou des
personnalités mais continuent à avoir ce
mouvement ou verra son cas aux europe et
si vraiment il va décider de marcher
seul comme je ne voulais pas d'un grand
sens très beau les sur une chose c'est
que le point commun kit considérablement
accentuée à l'ère des écrans c'est le
besoin de neuf alors même si le 9 s'est
nourrie du vieux le neuf c'est une
personne 9,7 un visage neuf c'est à dire
c'est quelqu'un de différent
quelqu'un qui n'était pas candidat
avance quelqu'un qu'on n'avait pas vu
mais c'est pas pour rien que l'italie
est basse et justement c'est pas beau
sic et 10 à la tête de la ligue et c'est
pas griot qui était à la tête de cinq
étoiles mais ce sont des hommes entre
guillemets 9
évidemment que c'est pas une meuf sur le
fond mais ils apparaissent 9 et c'est
quelque chose qui sait un jour c'est un
travail qu'on célèbre de rappeler
qu'elle n'est pas du tout dans ses idées
donc la fille je sais plus de qui elle
est qui disait il faut dix ans pour
faire un président de la république je
ne paraît plus adapté au temps politique
chantal delsol qui avait la dent un peu
dur contre marion maréchal qui disait
dans marianne la semaine dernière je
crois qu'il faudrait d'abord qu'elle
fasse un peu plus d'études parce que
c'est pas quelques années de droit qui
suffisent c'est là aussi c'est c'est
obsolète ce genre de comment
le nombre d'années d'études n'a jamais
été un critère d'éligibilité et l'est de
moins en moins si tenté que jamais et
les références à gramsci halla halla
métapolitique à la bataille culturelle
c'est un bonne elle est cédée pour un
mouvement conservateur qui va très au
delà d'elle mais qui existe 20 ça c'est
évident c'est à dire que jusqu'il ya une
quinzaine d'années il y avait une espèce
de partage des tâches où on faisait la
queue la culture et de gauche
l'intelligence et de gauche
et puis la droite et gestionnaire elle
et elle est douée en économie et tout ça
va s'entendre
et puis il ya eu au fait un brouillage
idéologique sur la pédagogie me semble
sur l'école et sur le multiculturalisme
qui a fait que des gens qui plaçaient de
gauche ont été classés à droite enfin et
qu'il ya eu ceux des sept lignes de
fracture que macron a très bien vu entre
conservateurs et progressistes mais pour
achever d'embrouillés mon propos le
ministre plus populaire de macron est un
ministre qui apparaît comme conservateur
dans toutes ses décisions puisque c'est
jean-michel laurent blanc quel est ce
qu'il est si effectivement vous avez
raison de dire qu'il est
particulièrement populaire mais il mais
il caractérise quand même un bon moment
qui va au-delà de la simple politique
mais qui effectivement un mouvement
culturel qui fait que si si si on prend
comme point de départ ce qui veux pas
déranger 11 mai 68 et les valeurs qui
ont pu aider
effectivement on sent que depuis
quelques années et bien un mouvement
beaucoup plus conservateur qui reprend
le dessus et que c'est là dessus qu'ils
servent de manière extrêmement
extrêmement clair extrêmement honorable
et avait expliqué dans le figaro pardon
il ya deux ans que il y avait une
poussée conservatrice de la haute
intelligentsia et une radicalisation de
la base intelligentsia vers l'extrême
gauche ce qui est donc c'était un mois
ou deux mois avant nuit debout
c'était assez bien vu les cailloux il ya
cette logique la sécu sans solution
parle d'économie parce que entre une
marion maréchal-le pen à wauquiez et
macron est beaucoup plus de deux
rapprochements que sa femme sur
l'économie les trois qui étaient
incarnés très dirigiste en économie qui
serait construit comme marcher vite
passer tous et personne ne savait pas
que ce soit ce n'est pas que je sois
question pour cette loi et qu elle veut
c soir à travers son école voilà et veut
créer une forme de ce que j'appelais
corpus doctrine qu'on n'ira pas jusque
là mais avoir des genres tout et qui
travaillent pour elles pour créer un
corpus culturel culturelle et sociétale
avant d'aborder des questions
économiques ça c'est un conte et
quelques réactions pour terminer sur ce
thème josselin qui nous dit ce retour en
politique
huit seraient favorables vu l'état du
front national macabre ronito ça va être
étrange de devoir oublier le pen à la
fin de marion marshall en sommes tous un
peu de mal quand même c'est vrai cet
effacement rien a assez elle avait
utilisé quand ça lui servait pour
c'était je crois pour les régionales au
départ et puis anti mac 2.0 marion
maréchal est très intelligente si elle
revient c'est la mort de la droite
républicaine altaï cas c'est l'opposé de
macron qui a la beauté d'un commercial à
la fois très avenant et veut envoyer
vous avez des vous écoutent
attentivement olivier duhamel à la fois
très avenant et avec je ne sais quoi de
faux dérangeant amir 4 le succès son
retour dépendra de son projet politique
du réchauffé ou un projet totalement
nouveau est porteur altaïque encore elle
incarne la droite réactionnaire que le
pen père avait séduit et que marine le
pen peine à garder et à rien de verso
l'attrait pour certains vers marion
marion maréchal tient au fait que la
droite et mettent actuellement c'est
vrai on en a parlé je pense honnêtement
que niveau économique elle ne maîtrise
pas mieux les dossiers que sa tante elle
est une bonne communicante complète
macabre nito eh bien on va passer à
notre dernier thème qui n'a rien à voir
mais ça fait parler beaucoup c'est 7
loto du patrimoine il est lancé par
emmanuel macron et magnin mâcon qui a
choisi le château de voltaire à ferney
cet après-midi pour lancer donc ce loto
et au passage de leur délivrer un
message politique en décrivant voltaire
comme un esprit libre dans un temps où
la religion servette a justifié le pire
et aussi la tyrannie du politique alors
ce loto il est destiné à sauver les
monuments en péril
il commencera en septembre on a choisi
de vous demander quels monuments ou
éléments du patrimoine vous aimeriez
sauver on attend vos réponses
internautes
êtes-vous un tour de table rapide vous y
avez réfléchi vincent moi j'y réfléchis
mais je sais pas si c'est parce qu'il ya
plusieurs monuments et que sont des
chapelles on est obligé de choisir
relève c'est peut-être une entorse à la
laïcité mais je cours comme vous le dire
il y a encore ce une couronne de
chapelles romanes paysanne qui va de
bastia et qui va jusqu'à saint florent
qui sont absolument extraordinaires dans
lequel on peut voir quelques restes de
fresques on s'en approche etc et qui
sont en très mauvais état et souvent
quand j'ai des rêves d'autres vie je me
dis je vais faire une fondation pour
essayer de sauver ces chapelles donc
voilà si elle pouvait être dans l'auto
du patrimoine ça s'est réalisé le début
de mon rêve mais chez pas donc si ça
rentre dans le cadre un autre rêve d'une
autre vie tu verdict osmanovic mais moi
j'ai regardé la liste et puis je les
aimais ça et puis ça et puis ça aussi
mais en fait je ne choisis pas parce que
c'est une démarche que je trouve sur le
four net vous n'approuvez pas du tout la
démarche c'est pas il ya tellement de
magnifiques endroits à sauver elles ne
le sont pas parce que là encore l'état
ne finance pas l'état ne finance pas
parce que les politiques d'austérité et
conte avec la culture est l'un des
premiers un des premiers budgets que
l'on efface et le faire par l'auto mais
qu'est ce qu'on peut imaginer de moins
citoyens que ça nous parce que j'aurai
quand j'ai pensé soumis le sujet je me
suis dit mais ce qu'il faudrait faire
c'est laisser passer par les écoles que
chaque école dans son coin
et puis qu'ils aillent qu'on incite les
enfants à parler à leurs parents et que
les parents cotisent âtre et puis que
les enfants apportent l'argent et puis
de manière anonyme et qu'on est un
mouvement citoyen de sauvegarde ou tout
l'argent va à la sauvegarde des
monuments mais là ce qui va se passer
c'est qu'on va gratter jouer au loto en
espérant en fait tu deviens riche et
gagner de l'argent et puis à peine 20 %
vont aller aux monuments historiques
s'effacer du maquereau voilà c'est le
bling bling et c'est c'est la fin de
l'état et c'est la victoire de l'argent
du bling bling
olivier duhamel je vais en plus parce
que des accords et total est il au choix
que je vais faire en plus aggraver mon
cas
le désaccord est totale parce que pour
une fois qu'il ya une initiative ludique
sympathique marrante à laquelle veut pas
se participer plein de gens c'est pas
tous les jours que ça arrive parce que
c'est un mécénat c'est une sorte de
mécénat collectif qui mobilise beaucoup
de citoyens et ses joyeux parce que de
toute façon je vous signale qu'en plus
le le bulletin il est à 15 euros donc
c'est nettement plus cher on va vous
grattez jamais vous et si vous ratez
quand même 20 20 gré des saisons que
c'est quand même un effort rudy
participer et alors jag rappelons qu'à
part le choix j'ai pas vu la liste donc
je peux pas vous dire mais moi je
prendrais alors petit incident qui va
vous faire plaisir tout mécréants que je
sois notre dame de paris
j'ai découvert qu'elle est en très
mauvais état que notre dame de paris
était en très mauvais état que ça
continue avec ça se dégrader
considérablement je comprends même pas
comment c'est possible que ce soit
alors il son bilan je viens à ma femme
parce que il débute été abandonnée on
est malheureusement au terme de cette
émission mathieu votre choix
déjà juste pour comme il est question de
privatiser de privatiser la française
des jeux
il va falloir faire attention parce
qu'effectivement si on organise son loto
du patrimoine dans l'esprit
effectivement lui dit qui est plutôt
sympathique
et puis pourquoi pas c'est une façon de
financer des travaux dont tac mais il
faut pas non plus privatisé d'un autre
côté la procédure
au-delà de ça moi j'ai gardé si j'ai
pensé au plan banlieues la croix je me
suis dit est-ce qu'on peut sauver le
plan borloo et le plan banlieue via le
ben ali a très très peu de sites dans
les banlieues en tout cas parisienne
mais j'en ai trouvé un
il ya un site en seine-saint-denis alors
à saint-denis même qui le couvent des
ursulines et
je me suis penché un petit peu sur la
documentation et j'ai vu que c'était un
couvent en particulier où anne
d'autriche avait caché son fils le futur
louis xiv au moment de la fronde qui a
été transformé en appartements mais il
ya une partie qui demeure visitables et
j'ai regardé les photos c'est dans un
état absolument détestable
donc si on pouvait passer un petit coup
de neuf dessus ce serait se seraient
formées ce diplomate au fait le port
l'autoroute comme pour récupérer
seulement 20 millions c'est l'objectif
c'est 20 millions faut le gagner des
millions c'est un château vous restaurer
un château un sacré bon je pense quand
même que là il ya quelque chose d'un
coup de com non pas forcément
il peut y avoir ça existe parfois
l'enthousiasmé collectif s'est pas
seulement de la communication est là le
patrimoine français quand même quelque
chose qui réconcilie à peu près tout le
monde et l'organisation que donne macron
le choix de stéphane bern se fait à peu
près consensus aussi après on va voir
vous savez pas voir mais malheureux mais
ce qu'ils arrivent pas travailler que
les avec l'administration qui est censé
travailler parce qu'ils découvrent ils
n'ont pas d'argent en fait et lui
malheureux il ya un type il aimerait que
ce soit comme ça
malheureusement je retiendrai donc vos
choix je les rappelle quand même des
chapelles romanes en corse pour vincent
très molle et notre dame de paris
carrément faut corriger duhamel et
mathieu le couvent des ursulines en
seine saint denis c'est bien ça je n'ai
pas malheureusement le temps de donner
vos choix pour vous internautes mais
continue à vous exprimer sur ce sujet et
rendez vous demain pour un nouveau point
de vue
[Musique]